welcome back household leaks can account
for more than 10 000 gallons of water in
an average home every year so that adds
up and it shows up on your water bill
bianca holmen live to share some
information about fix a leak week bianca
it's so simple but can save so much
it can heather and so you may be
surprised to learn but about 10 percent
of homes well they leak about 90 gallons
of water a day and that's a lot when you
think about where we live we live in a
there's a need to conserve water and
we're out here at the sahara park where
there's this man-made lake but several
homes all around so fix a leak is very
very important campaign again to help us
conserve water here in our environment
common places to check faucets shower
heads and other fixtures during the
winter if it
exceeds 12
gallons a month
many leaks around the home can be fixed
with
hardware and all this week there's a
push to fix leaks around your home and
find water to conserve it has a major
impact on our environment
we are in a drought and every drop of
water counts
and when the water is
dripping in a leaky faucet that water is
wasted we are not using it it is treated
water its potable water and it goes
straight to waste
we can all at times leave the water
running i know i'm guilty but here's a
list of uh ways to save water around
your home turn off the water while
brushing your teeth turn off your the
water while in between shaving and then
use when you're using the washing
machine use it only for full loads the
same goes with your dishwasher only for
full loads of dishes to wash and use
your dishwasher so all great tips and of
course
use this week to figure out if you have
any leaks around your home and of course
we'll have this information listed on
our website so you can refer to it
reporting live bianca holmen live local
now save water save money bianca thank
you we appreciate that